i
[Música]
cuarto día de conteo tras las elecciones
estadounidenses cauto pero esperanzado
el demócrata joe biden habló por tercera
vez indicó que ganará con una clara
mayoría y anunció que ya trabaja para
enfrentar la pandemia en su eventual
mandato por su parte el presidente de
unalt ump aseguró que su rival no
debería declararse ganador pues sus
demandas sobre los resultados apenas
inician
francia rinde un sentido homenaje a las
tres víctimas que dejó el atentado
terrorista perpetrado en misa el pasado
29 de octubre el primer ministro galos
ran castex expresó las condolencias de
toda la nación a niza y se mostró
indignado y conmovido por las víctimas
al tiempo que el alcalde de niza
cristian es posible y dio resistencia
ante el extremismo
bolivia está lista para la posesión de
luís arce como nuevo presidente este
domingo la investidura marca el regreso
del partido movimiento al socialismo al
poder aunque hay protestas en la región
de santa cruz bastión opositor se prevé
que evo morales- vuelva a la nación este
lunes
bienvenidos gracias por acompañarnos en
esta nueva emisión de noticias en
france24 soy valentina torres sánchez
iniciamos en eeuu donde se cumplen
cuatro días desde las elecciones
presidenciales sin que se haya declarado
un ganador el candidato demócrata joe
biden rosa una reñida victoria ha tomado
la delantera en georgia pensilvania y
nevada y sigue de primero en arizona que
en las próximas horas actualizará
resultados by the end que volvió a
hablar anoche desde wilmington en el
estado de delaware se dijo seguro de
ganar aseguró que su intención es unir
al país y que ya trabaja con su fórmula
vicepresidencial y un grupo de expertos
para enfrentar la pandemia por su parte
el presidente de donald trump que
encabeza el conteo en carolina del norte
y alaska llamó a su rival a no proclamar
el triunfo diciendo que las demandas
sobre el resultado apenas empiezan
estas dudas de la política no vamos a
estar de acuerdo en muchas visiones pero
podemos estar de acuerdo en ser cívicos
seguro con el otro y menos hay que poner
la ira y la demonización atrás hay que
reunirnos como nación y sanar y esto no
va a ser fácil tenemos que intentarlo mi
responsabilidad como presidente será
representar a toda la nación vamos ahora
hasta la ciudad de filadelfia en el
estado de pensilvania toda la corte
suprema le ordenó a los colegios
electorales estatales separar las
papeletas que llegaron después de las
ocho de la noche del 3 de noviembre este
estado es considerado clave por los 20
votos electorales que aporta más
temprano hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala quien nos contó
cómo avanza el conteo allí y si tomara
más del tiempo estimado pues ese conteo
avanzan de nuevo muy lentamente para que
os hagáis una idea desde ayer sólo se ha
avanzado menos del 1 por ciento en ese
recuento de votos como decías
pensilvania podría ser la llave directa
a la casa blanca para el demócrata joe
biden pero la pregunta ahora es
y bien esto que comentaba es
precisamente esa apelación esa
proclamación de la corte suprema que ha
aceptado la petición del partido
republicano de separar los votos
llegados después del 3 de noviembre pero
con fecha anterior al 3 de noviembre
podría ralentizar este proceso esos
votos se van a apartar y se contarán
aparte pero como digo esto podría
demorar todavía más ese conteo en estos
momentos aquí en pensilvania todavía
quedan cerca de 90 mil papeletas por
abrirse y si hacemos caso a la tendencia
que hemos visto hasta ahora esas
papeletas podrían favorecer notoriamente
a los demócratas porque hasta ahora esas
papeletas por correo así ha sido le han
favorecido a los demócratas y además
provienen de los puntos más demócratas
de este estado así que esa diferencia
esa ventaja de 28.000 de 833 votos que
lleva ahora mismo el demócrata joe biden
podría verse ampliada además de la
disputa por la presidencia demócratas y
republicanos aún sostienen una batalla
por el control del senado y de la cámara
de representantes- según los resultados
aún parciales
demócrata mantendrá el control de la
cámara y los republicanos están en una
fuerte carrera por mantener el control
del senado de la conformación de estas
entidades dependerá el margen de
maniobra que tendrá el próximo
mandatario para gobernar veamos más
detalles en el informe de aurora valle
y aunque el duelo entre joe biden y
donald trump está absorbiendo toda la
atención no es sólo la presidencia la
que está en juego en eeuu los votantes
también designan a otros miles de cargos
desde senadores hasta sheriff y
legisladores locales en cuanto a los 435
escaños de la cámara de representantes
los resultados parciales sugieren una
ventaja para los demócratas se
presentaron a las elecciones de esta
semana con grandes esperanzas de
aumentar su control mayoritario de la
cámara pero el partido sufre hasta el
momento la pérdida de cerca de seis
escaños
además distritos como iowa incluso una
parte de california que los demócratas
habían recuperado en 2018 no
permanecieron azules we don't know when
pero no ganamos todos los batallas pero
ganamos la guerra los estadounidenses
también fueron llamados el martes para
renovar un tercio del senado por una
parte los republicanos conquistaron
estados clave pero no han conseguido los
escaños necesarios para declarar que
ostentan la mayoría las esperanzas
demócratas ahora descansan en georgia
este estado podría en efecto definir
la inclinación del senado pero la
carrera parece encaminarse a una segunda
vuelta
espero que el resultado de las
elecciones sea positivo porque todos nos
llevamos bien realmente ambos partidos
se llevan bien espero realmente espero
que los asientos en el senado sigan
siendo los mismos para que puedan
aprender a llevarse bien
los estadounidenses tendrán que ser
pacientes para saber los resultados
finales ya que ante este contexto en
algunos casos no se resolverá sino hasta
el próximo año y ahora el riesgo es que
el próximo presidente se quede sin una
mayoría clara en el senado y la cámara y
el medio del conteo las cifras de
contagios de kobe 19 en eeuu no son
alentadoras en la última jornada del
país rompió por tercer día consecutivo
el récord de nuevos casos y reportó 127
mil 21 el jefe de gabinete de la casa
blanca mark meadows dio positivo por
coronavirus según medios estadounidenses
el funcionario estuvo junto al
presidente de trump en la noche de las
elecciones y en las oficinas de campaña
más temprano
y en ninguno de estos lugares portó
mascarilla
vamos ahora a europa porque francia
rinde este sábado un homenaje a las tres
víctimas mortales que dejó el atentado
terrorista en la ciudad de niza el
pasado 29 de octubre la ceremonia es
presidida por el primer ministro francés
yann castex quien expresó en nombre de
toda la nación compasión por las
víctimas e indignación por lo ocurrido
al homenaje también asistieron las
familias de los dos franceses y la
brasileña asesinados en medio del ataque
vine a compartir a las personas de niza
en presencia suya señor alcalde mi
sentimiento mi compasión y mi
indignación estos sentimientos los
comparte toda la nación inicia el 29 de
octubre el terrorismo fue en contra de
la libertad de culto como ya lo había
hecho antes fin de ajuste el 26 de julio
de 2016 cuando un padre fue degollado
cuando estaba celebrando su misa en una
celebración religiosa es una ofensa en
una república laica que respeta la
religión por lo que ella es que respecto
a la religión puse que lee
y combatir el terrorismo es una
prioridad para el continente europeo que
se ha visto impulsada tras los atentados
recientes en francia y austria los
gobiernos invierten en procesos de
desradicalización de jóvenes islamistas
francia acordó con el gobierno de túnez
extraditará tunecinos en situación
irregular mientras que en austria las
autoridades cerraran mezquitas
consideradas como radicales veamos más
en el informe de andré amaya
un homenaje en la ciudad de niza a las 3
personas que perdieron la vida en el
ataque terrorista el ministro del
interior francés estuvo de visita en
túnez país de donde provenía el atacante
con el fin de extraditar a un grupo de
ciudadanos tunecinos en situación
irregular en francia
consideramos que esta ideología no tiene
nada que ver con las religiones como
bien lo dijo usted pero esta ideología
hay que combatirla le agradezco señor
ministro después del largo intercambio
que tuvimos para poder seguir haciendo
este trabajo para intercambiar nuestra
información
y luchar contra aquellos que quieren
destruir nuestra amistad y la relación
fraterna entre nuestros pueblos
la hora su patrón de la fruta el primer
ministro jan que ustedes preside el
homenaje también estará presente el ex
presidente nicolas sarkozy si francia es
el país con la población musulmana más
numerosa de europa austria tienen su
suelo una de las mayores concentraciones
musulmanas del continente en proporción
a su población de 89 millones de
habitantes el gobierno ordenó el cierre
de mezquitas radicales tras el atentado
en viena perpetrado por un islamista
radical que asesinó a cuatro personas
es colonizada en escalones para bandas
no puede ser verdad que los jóvenes de
hoy piensen que van al cielo si matan a
alguien el imán dijo que es culpa de los
padres creo que los padres son en parte
culpables tienen que hacer seguimiento
de la educación de sus hijos miembros de
la comunidad musulmana judía y cristiana
en berlín se reunieron frente a la
embajada de austria en homenaje a las
víctimas las autoridades germanas buscan
actualmente a cuatro personas que se
cree tenían vínculos con el atacante de
viena continuamos en europa y dejamos el
extremismo para hablar de coronavirus la
segunda ola de kobe 19 no da tregua en
este continente las cifras de la
organización mundial de la salud indican
que ya hay más de 12 millones de casos y
300.000 muertes en europa los gobiernos
de varios países continúan imponiendo
restricciones para controlar los
contagios una de las situaciones más
críticas se presenta en francia donde
este viernes se registró un nuevo récord
con 60 mil 468 nuevos positivos en 24
horas
y reino unido volvieron al confinamiento
e italia ya acumula más de 800 mil
contagios en total en parís el ministro
de transporte francés explicó como
controlarán la situación en los
aeropuertos y luego la idea es aislar a
las personas positivas sean
asintomáticas o no tratarlas rastrear
los casos positivos y cortar las cadenas
de circulación del virus esta misma
filosofía este mismo método de operación
está en línea con el conjunto de
dispositivos que hemos desplegado con
las pruebas de antígenos en las salidas
a partir de hoy y en las llegadas la
próxima semana ósea
y vamos ahora está áfrica porque
continúa la atención en etiopía el
parlamento de ese país aprobó una
resolución que le permite al gobierno
nacional formar un ejecutivo de
transición interino en la región del
tigre la imposición de un gobierno
interino se produce en medio de los
enfrentamientos entre el frente de
liberación del tigre que controla la
región y es considerado rebelde por el
ejecutivo nacional la atención es tan
alta que el primer ministro etíope y
premio nobel de paz 2019 había met le
declaró la guerra a esa organización y
lanzó una ofensiva militar en la región
cambiamos de continente vamos a américa
latina porque este lunes luís arce se
posesiona como nuevo presidente de
bolivia lo que marca el regreso del
movimiento al socialismo al poder así
mismo se concreta la oportunidad de
regreso prevista para el lunes del ex
mandatario evo morales- exiliado en
argentina se prevé que el ex presidente
de una conferencia de prensa en las
próximas horas mientras que continúan
las protestas en la región de santa cruz
bastión opositor que piden frenar la
posición la posesión andrés meza muñoz
tiene los detalles
y en un simbólico ritual indígena luízar
se recibió el bastón de mando que
representa el liderazgo que asumirá como
presidente de bolivia este 8 de
noviembre ar se tomará juramento tras
lograr una aplastante victoria en las
pasadas elecciones del 18 de octubre
recibimos en tiawanaku la energía de la
pachamama y los ancestros para gobernar
en paz unidad y prosperidad no
defraudaremos la confianza del pueblo al
dejar el cargo de presidente de bolivia
ar se relevará a yanine años quien
asumió el poder de forma interina en
2019 tras unas fallidas elecciones
presidenciales que provocaron la salida
del ex presidente evo morales y sumieron
al país en una crisis política a su
ceremonia asistirán los presidentes de
argentina alberto fernández de colombia
iván duque y de paraguay mario abdo
benítez así como el rey felipe sexto de
españa y una serie de delegaciones de
los países vecinos la instalación de
arse en el gobierno fue la oportunidad
para que evo morales regresará al país
tras haber estado exiliado en argentina
el ex mandatario tiene previsto llegar a
bolivia por vía terrestre este lunes en
medio de una caravana
en la que recorrerá varias ciudades no
está claro si morales planea
reintegrarse a la vida pública sin
embargo su heredero luís arce dejó claro
que no habrá un papel para él en este
gobierno tenemos ahora una noticia que
enluta al cine y a la política argentina
falleció el reconocido director de cine
fernando pino solanas a los 84 años por
coronavirus nos disculpamos pues nuestra
emisión anterior hubo un error en las
imágenes del celebrado documentalista
solanas murió en parís donde trabajaba
como embajador de su país ante la unesco
el director es recordado por su
militancia en la izquierda argentina y
su extensa trayectoria cinematográfica
que le valió multitud de premios
nacionales e internacionales
y vamos ahora a dar un vistazo a lo que
registra nuestra página web france24
puntocom en portada tenemos un minuto a
minuto de las elecciones estadounidenses
con joe biden que no se declara ganador
pero ya adelanta su agenda presidencial
también trump que divide a los
republicanos tras sus acusaciones sin
evidencia de fraude electoral y los
resultados minuto a minuto de las
elecciones en una infografía he estado
por estado
llegamos hacia el final de este
informativo y recuerden que pueden
ampliar toda esta información en france
24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]